JOSH LIVNI: --this week's
Maps Developer
Relations office hours.
My name is Josh Livni.
I want to introduce here Paul
Saxman, a relatively new
member of our team here on
Maps Developer Relations.
And we're going to cover a few
things this week starting out
with a review of some of our
launches at Google I/O.
So every year, we have this
large Google I/O conference.
Tons of things get announced.
It's easy to miss one or two,
so we wanted to give some
details on some of the things
that relate to the Maps API
specifically and
the Places API.
So just a quick recap, there's
quite a few people at Moscone
Center in San Francisco, lots
of people watching globally.
You can watch most of the
videos already up at our
YouTube channel and
I/O website.
And we're going to go ahead and
roll through some of the
features starting now that we
post about on the blog and
give a little bit
of extra detail.
So why don't we get started
with our Places API?
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, absolutely.
So we announced four major
enhancements to the Google
Places API, Google I/O.
One of the big ones--
and this is all in response to
what developers were really
asking for.
So hopefully, we hit
some of your most
favorite feature request.
Google Reviews was one of the
enhancements that we added.
The Reviews are actually
available in
two different forms.
One is actually in the Place
search response.
You can tell if a place is
actually open at the time of
the request.
And that's just actually a
Boolean flag that's past.
It's open now.
And the other one is actually in
the Places detail request,
which gives you actually
hours of operation.
So you get an array back that
actually gives you the full
hours the place is open.
Text search is another thing
that we announced at Google
I/O. Text search is a little
different than keyword search
in that text search is actually
good for actually
voice input.
So if somebody is saying
something like sushi near
Sydney or pizza in New York
City, we actually process
that, determine what you're
searching on and where you're
searching, and then issue
the query from there.
So the results look a lot like
the place search results.
Oh wait.
So I got that backwards.
So Google Reviews said the
opening hours are actually
part of the search
and the details--
places search and
places detail.
Reviews are also in there now.
Reviews are only in the
place detail search.
You get those back as
an array as well.
I believe you get in there, you
get the ranking and the
actual comments that
the user provided.
JOSH LIVNI: The five most
popular reviews, the reviews
that we think give the best
impression of the place.
So it should you a good idea of
how people like it or not.
PAUL SAXMAN: Right.
And the last one I'm going to
mention, this is actually one
of my favorites, pagination.
So a lot of people were
a little worried--
you only got 20 results back.
We allow developers now
to paginate and get
back up to 60 results.
And the way that works is you
issue the places search query,
you get back 20 results.
And you get a key that you can
use to actually get the next
20 results.
And when you get the next
20, you get another key.
You use that key to
get the next 20.
So you get up to 60 total.
There's slight delay between
when you can make those.
So you don't want to just
try to pull down
all 60 at one time.
Wait just a short
period of time.
JOSH LIVNI: Maybe we should give
a couple of demos of what
the actual results
look like here in
some of the new features.
Here, we have a place search for
my neighborhood, Glen Park
in San Francisco, looking
for some tea or coffee.
Tea, in this case, is
a keyword search.
And yup.
We get our usual places back.
And you can see the big
difference here is the opening
hours, not sure if you
guys can see that.
I'll just make it even bigger.
And you're just going to Boolean
here, is it open right
now, which is super useful.
So you can get back your 20 or
60 places and easily filter
for ones that are open or not.
PAUL SAXMAN: And the structure
here is actually the same as
you'll see in the places details
results for open now.
So if you go to the open--
JOSH LIVNI: Here's the
coffee shop I got my
coffee at this morning.
And if we scroll down, we can
see we have our new opening
hours here which fall
the various days.
So the day [INAUDIBLE]
I believe Sunday or Monday?
PAUL SAXMAN: I believe so.
JOSH LIVNI: I think Sunday.
And they have different hours
for the various days, which is
again, super useful.
PAUL SAXMAN: All of our
documentation has been updated.
So if you go to the Google
Places API documentation, all
this information is in there.
So if you're trying to parse
this, it should be pretty
straightforward.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah.
And I think we've already
mentioned this in the past
hangout, the three-dimensional
Zagat ratings here that you
can get, the different aspects
of the different businesses.
So it's super useful there
as well with the reviews.
So yeah, check out the new
features of Places API.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yup.
Do we have the--
This one has some comments
in it as
well, the Google Reviews.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah.
So you get the sort of
full text of the
review and pretty useful.
PAUL SAXMAN: And you get
user's rating as well.
So you get their ratings.
You get their comments.
And then you get a link to
the author information.
JOSH LIVNI: Yup.
All right.
I think that covers it.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
I think that's everything.
Now on to--
JOSH LIVNI: Oh yeah.
We have a little demo here.
I guess we could the
same thing here.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
So this is actually
on the blog.
So we cover a lot of
the announcements
on the blog as well.
And what you should be seeing
now is actually just a quick
demo of using the API in
a web application.
JOSH LIVNI: Take the coffee
shop, and you could lay it out
more nicely from the JSON
response, of course.
All right.
Yeah.
So Places API, scrolling down.
Next one is Styled Maps, a
couple of new features there.
Styled Maps, you all should be
using Styled Maps for sure
change our default base map.
So we've optimized it well
for maps.google.com.
But you probably have
a different story.
Perhaps faded out to get
some overlays on top.
Perhaps make some things
more prominent.
Perhaps remove some features.
So in addition to the existing
granularity of all the things
that you can subtract from the
map and change, we've added a
few key new features.
The main ones are the ability
to set the color directly.
Previously, you could
set the relative
hues, saturation, gamma.
But you couldn't specify
an RGB value.
For example, I want the
rows to be exactly
this color of red.
And so now you can.
And that's very,
very powerful.
So it's much easier to have
the map match your brand.
If you have a logo, you already
know your colors.
You have a set of palettes that
you like to work with.
You can easily choose the custom
colors for the map to
match your site.
So that's really nice.
The best way to do this, and
I'll show you the features
here in a demo, is as always,
use our Styled Maps Wizard.
Let's see if I can figure
out how to open
Styled Maps Wizard here.
I usually just do it by typing
in Styled Maps Wizard in a
search engine.
You should get the result
pretty quickly.
And here, we have a
tool that lets you
create the Styled Map.
So for example, I often
like to turn
everything off right away.
So I'll just go ahead and
turn everything off.
It's not a very exciting map.
I'll add that style.
And then I can start turning
some things on.
So for example, it could
turn on Roads.
Turn them on.
I won't see anything right
now because I'm
not zoomed in enough.
But if zoom to say, Seattle,
I should see
some roads for Seattle.
So what's cool now as I go here
is I can say I just want
the geometry of the roads.
And also, here's
a new feature.
Choose just the fill or just
the stroke of the roads.
And each of those can be
styled individually.
So the fill and the stroke
have separate
styles, pretty powerful.
And the other feature that we've
added is the ability to
change the weight.
So I can take the weight and
make, for example, really kind
of cartoony fat roads, which is
kind of fun, or really thin
roads if I just want things
more faded out.
So I could, for example, take
some really thin roads and get
a really subtle style.
And then maybe if I want to
emphasize the transit, get
some really big transit.
Now, I have a map that kind
of minimizes the roads,
emphasizes the transit.
Not a very pretty map,
but you get the idea.
There's a lot of ability to
really not only turn things on
and off, but really emphasize
and deemphasize in a much more
subtle way with the ability to
weight the stroke and the
fill, and set the color.
So check out the newest
Styled Map features.
You can really make some
amazing stuff now.
PAUL SAXMAN: Can I use this
to do 8-bit maps?
JOSH LIVNI: Not quite
the 8-bit maps.
We're getting closer.
One day.
PAUL SAXMAN: Can it do
a Middle Earth map?
Can you make it look like--
JOSH LIVNI: I've definitely seen
some people start to get
a little bit more of those
old-style map fields with
their own custom icons and
so forth on top, fading
things in and out.
But yeah.
We're adding more and more
features to the different
types and styles.
So keep them coming.
Your feature requests
are super helpful.
We look at those as always and
look forward to seeing you
guys implement some pretty
nice-looking styled maps here.
Oh yeah.
Next.
These are really exciting
features to the Maps API, the
Symbols and the Heatmap.
The Symbol Edition is probably
my favorite thing I saw
launched at I/O this year.
Super powerful.
I'm just going open
up a tab here that
shows some marker symbols.
You can apply the symbols to
polylines or to markers.
If you apply them to the markers
here, you can see that
cool animation effects.
What we're playing here
is opening of
Walmart stores over time.
So a lot of them opened.
It's pretty impressive.
PAUL SAXMAN: The data is as
amazing as [INAUDIBLE].
JOSH LIVNI: And it really has
a lot of [INAUDIBLE].
I'm just throwing a lot of
markers on the map to call out
with an animation effect, which
is really easy to do,
where they're opening.
So they don't get lost in the
noise in the East Coast there
and then recolor
them over time.
Get rid of that message.
And yeah.
So I definitely recommend
checking out the Symbols.
They're done with SVG.
So it works on most
modern browsers.
And then, let's take a look at
the kind of thing you can do
with the polylines here.
PAUL SAXMAN: A quick question
[INAUDIBLE].
So it's SVGs and animations,
right?
So you specify multiple SVGs to
get an animation, or you do
transitions?
JOSH LIVNI: I'll show you
right here in the code.
What you do--
it's not too much code.
Actually, this one is a
little more complex.
It's mostly has to
do with the time.
But yeah, you can probably
use it just to go in the
documentation, look at
the property there.
But you can set the
radius, the color.
And what we do is we make the
radius a little bit bigger for
just a second or so and then
fade out the opacity.
And so you can dynamically
change the stroke, the fill
color, the radius, and of
course, the opacity.
And with a combination of
those effects, you get a
pretty nice looking
transition there.
So that's how that
one was done.
And on Polylines, it's
even more impressive.
This is not any particular data
set but just showing that
we can set the symbols along a
polyline animated, works on
geodesic lines like
you can see here.
And you can do arbitrary SVG
paths that you can define,
allowing you to do complex
symbols, arrows that are
custom, set the distance they
are along the lines in pixels
or in percentage of the line
like we have here, and then
again, animate them.
So you could imagine a set of
airports with planes flying.
Not too much code.
Get some really, really
beautiful animations here.
So definitely check
out the Symbols.
Very, very cool stuff.
And similarly, the Heatmap,
it's the same data set.
So it'll take a little while to
get started but can accept
tens of thousands of individual
Lat/Longs.
And then, there's a bunch of
parameters on the heatmap.
So here, we see the same
Walmart data set slowly
growing up over time.
And I'll just quickly show you
what it can look like with
some of the options here.
So here's some GPS traces
through San Francisco.
You can imagine already if
you were to show these as
individual markers, it would be
a little less interesting
and doesn't show you that
relative density.
But we have some ability
to change the
colors really easily.
You just set a gradient for
how you want that to look.
You can change the radius of the
heatmap, so if you want to
emphasize or deemphasize if you
have relatively large or
small number of markers, and
of course, the opacity.
So playing with these values,
you can get a
really nice data set.
And as you can see in the
example back here on the blog
post of the Walmart stores, just
dynamically adding a new
Lat/Long to your array will
change the heatmap.
So you create a pretty dynamic
heatmap story as well.
PAUL SAXMAN: That's very cool.
Obviously, that's a styled
map as well, right?
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah.
And as always, there's just
no excuse for using a
default-based map.
You should use the styled
maps for sure.
In this case, we just faded out
the background, because
the story we want to tell
doesn't need to emphasize
where the freeways are,
And the last major release
was Transit Directions.
So this is available--
all the places that we have
transit for maps.google.com
with the exception of Japan.
So that's a very large
number of major
cities around the world.
So very, very cool, the number
one feature request in Maps
API that we finally were able
to get all the data for and
provide to you.
So we're really excited
about it.
I won't go into all the details
of what you get back
in the Transit API.
But it's available as
a web service and to
the JavaScript API.
And you basically make a
directions request, except
choosing your mode as transit
instead, for example, driving,
or walking, or bicycling in the
United States or Canada.
So you choose the transit.
And if it's available in that
metro, we will give back to
you quite a lot of detail
including the upcoming times,
similar to walking directions if
you have to walk there, how
long you have to wait for, if
you miss the bus or whatever,
actually I think about 40
different types transit types,
not just buses, of course, the
expected wait time for the
next one, and just a ton of
information that you can use
to build up a really nice
display for the user.
Or you can use the standard
directions panel renderer.
And we'll give you something
that looks like this that
looks pretty good and is
familiar to Maps users.
So yeah, this works
really well.
And I think it will allow a
lot new mashups and people
using these transit
directions.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
And the departure time, I think,
was definitely key from
a user interface perspective.
I mean a lot of people actually
change the window for
when they're having
that in the API.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah.
So you can set any
starting time.
We give you back when the trains
are coming in your
local time in UTC.
Yeah, it's a very
flexible API.
And I hope you guys make
good use of it.
I think that's it for our
major features here.
Oh, one other thing on the
Transit API, we've also made
available a transit layer,
just as we have a weather
layer, bicycling layer, a
traffic layer, and so forth.
There's now a transit layer,
which you can add just two
lines of code by instantiating
a new transit layer and then
setting the transit
layer map to Map.
You now get that custom
transit layer
background as well.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
These were the main
API announcements.
But we also had a few non-API
announcements, for example,
the new 3D MyApps or 3D--
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah.
So that was pretty
exciting stuff.
It's not directly applicable
to developers today.
But in Google Earth, we are now
modeling major urban areas
in automated way using
computer vision.
And some of the aerial photos,
the oblique imagery, we're
able to automatically create
these really beautiful 3D
models that give
you a much more
natural feel to the landscape.
So definitely check out
on your Mobile.
This was the first time, I
think, in Google Earth that
we've launched on
mobile first.
So on your iPad or Android
device, you can download the
latest Google Earth and zoom in
to, I think it was about 12
cities launched now.
I'm not sure what they
all are off hand.
Rome, that's a really
cool one.
Check out the Coliseum and the
surrounding area, or as usual,
San Francisco, always a must
on the launch list.
Just a really, really nice
continuous, beautiful 3D set
of buildings.
That's very, very cool.
PAUL SAXMAN: And there was also
Coordinate that we'll probably--
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah.
I think we're going to have
an upcoming Office
Hours focusing on that.
We have an entirely new product
and associated API
that lets you manage teams of
people, workers, and jobs.
Won't get in too much detail
today, I think.
But check it out searching
for Google Coordinate.
And you can see it if you have
that kind of business use
case, a super powerful feature
for tracking where groups of
people are, managing it,
allowing them on their mobile
device to take upon certain
jobs, and get instantaneous
real-time feedback on
a set of dashboards.
But we're going to go in more
detail of that another day
PAUL SAXMAN: Right.
I see it's actually applicable
beyond just like work.
I mean you can actually
coordinate events and that
type of thing as well.
JOSH LIVNI: Oh, absolutely.
PAUL SAXMAN: It's a pretty
cool product.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah.
Anywhere you really have an
interest in groups of people,
where they're at, and things
they're doing [INAUDIBLE].
PAUL SAXMAN: Most of my dogfood
requests were meet
here for coffee.
Those were my jobs.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah.
We had some fun testing that
before running around for
random jobs we were
supposed to do.
I had to get a burrito
in a hurry.
PAUL SAXMAN: Nice.
JOSH LIVNI: It worked
out pretty well.
PAUL SAXMAN: Burrito for you.
You weren't a gopher,
were you, getting
burritos for everybody?
JOSH LIVNI: I ended up
getting two burritos.
So I think that pretty
much covers.
Do we have any questions
on the moderator?
Should we check that
really fast?
PAUL SAXMAN: Let me double
check really quick.
So a lot of people were asking
about the slides in videos.
Oh, we do have one
that came in.
So the question we got from
Jeremy in London, will we be
able to use the Styling Wizard
with terrain in the future?
We really need terrain, but
it does not seem to style.
JOSH LIVNI: So there's two
ways of looking at that.
One is can you change the style
that we do to terrain
itself, for example, hypsometric
shading or the
altitude that we use, and the
sun angle, and so forth, doing
grey scale hill shade?
And the other is can you apply
all of the styles that we
currently have with our roadmap
on top of the terrain?
So the first answer is no.
We currently pre-render all
of the terrain tiles.
And so as of today, that's the
base terrain that you get.
But the answer to the second
question is yes.
I'll just open up the Styled
Maps Wizard again here.
Start over and bring
up the terrain map.
Let's see if there's a demo
here on the terrain.
And by default, for example,
you could see we have the
labels and so forth.
But we can easily go ahead and
take this administrative
stuff, turn it off.
I can hit the Off button
and Style.
All the administrative
features go away.
PAUL SAXMAN: So you
can style the map.
You can't necessarily
style the tiles yet.
JOSH LIVNI: Exactly.
Yes.
So the base terrain
tiles, you can't.
But if you wanted to have
the terrain with--
let's add this one and turn
the roads off, you can
certainly do that.
And so all of the other things
such as the width and all the
other values that you can do
in regular styles, you can
also apply to terrain,
is really powerful.
So you get all the features that
you want associated with
the terrain.
But yeah, the base, the hill
shade, we currently don't let
you style today.
PAUL SAXMAN: And so one question
we got quite a bit
coming out of I/O was a lot of
people want the videos and
slides from I/O. And Josh
already mentioned--
just a little more detail
is that they're
all on the I/O website.
So if you just search for Google
I/O 2012, you go to the
I/O website.
You can look at the sessions
for Google Maps.
And each of the sessions, the
videos should all be up by
this point.
And the slides are actually
coming out this week,
hopefully by the end
of the week.
So stay tuned.
And if there's a particular
slide that you're looking for,
and it's not up there yet, just
let us know in Google+--
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah.
We'll send you a link,
absolutely.
PAUL SAXMAN: We'll
get to you guys.
JOSH LIVNI: I think
that covers us.
Thanks for joining us again.
We'll be back in, I think,
two weeks from Sydney.
So probably won't be us.
[INAUDIBLE].
PAUL SAXMAN: Not
any time soon.
JOSH LIVNI: So our Sydney
colleagues will to be up in a
couple weeks.
And we look forward
to chatting with
you more next time.
Cheers.
PAUL SAXMAN: Take it easy.